But, um, what have I done? I was in, we've been shooting. I shot guns for the,
for the first time. Uh, I shot a pistol and an M four.
I think that was what it was. That was what the Navy seals guys were telling me.
Um, the first day I was just like,
so it's weird to pick up like a killing machine, you know,
like something that's made for killing that's what was in my head.
And then the second day I was like, I felt like Ron wick,
I felt like I was like, John Wick's brother. I was like, I got this. Um,
but the, the empty rounds will fly out and hit your face. And that hot,
like summer on your face, dude. Um,
and that's like, you know, I was just thinking about like, okay,
like you hit targets. First of all, we don't have to hit targets.
Cause we're in a movie, you know what I'm talking about?
So you're doing that and you got the gun and then you, and then you got it.
And then it doesn't really matter. In the first time I was doing,
I was like trying to hit the target. And I was like, well,
I don't need to hit the target. It'll cut. And I'll hit the target.
It'll edit it into me, hitting the target. So I was like,
I gotta concentrate just on like drawing and like that. And, uh,
so I was drawing, so I would, I would do that and I would fire it and uh,
I dunno where I was going with this. But, uh, so I was really was, uh,
trying to do my, I don't know. Do you know what actually has been happening?
I've been looking at my phone too long and now it makes my brain dead.
It makes my brain like dude, before phones, I would think of stuff in the world.
Like, I'd be like, Oh, this is like, that. That's like this,
it would make me funny right now.
I just stare at Instagram or Twitter or whatever. And I just feel like, uh, uh,
uh, a piece of. Yeah. But I don't know.
But like, yeah, I used to think of, phones me up.
I used to think of and now I don't think of.
Like I was just at Starbucks and I noticed something that was funny at Starbucks
at Starbucks. Like when I was at Starbucks, this dude,
these two dudes walk in and there were S Albuquerque,
like one guy came in and had like tattoos all over. And he's real skinny.
If you're skinny and you got tattoos all over you're from Albuquerque.
And so he was like,
he was chilling with his other buddy and his other brother buddy looked, um,
like him, if he was on a,
if he was on a, like a, a workout plan, like he's a little healthier.
And they were sitting down and I wasn't looking behind me,
but they were talking.
And all I kept hearing was this dude who was like a,
a dog, a dog. Um, if it was real, the other guy's name was Chris. It's like,
Hey, Chris, he's like, take a, take a picture, take a picture of me, dog.
And then Chris took a into her and Chris like, laid that.
And then the guy was like, nah, man, come on, man.
I don't like a picture like that. And he was like, take a,
take a different picture of me dog. And Chris was like, nah, bro,
you gotta do it like this. He was like, nah, dog.
And he took another picture and he say, amen, come on, man.
Don't take a picture like that. I hate pictures like that.
That's what he was saying. And I was like, what the? Kind of pictures?
Like how they were in a Starbucks? Like what kind of picture is he taking?
I want it to turn around so bad, but I didn't want them to be like, Hey,
what the are you looking at, bro? You're not from here. So,
and I was like, thinking about how that was funny, you know? And I was like, ah,
dude, I can maybe make a bit about that.
And then I just started looking at my phone, forgot no bit.
There will be no bit about that. Not even on my pockets.
I'm talking about onstage.
If that's not going to be new material now because of Instagram,
uh, I was in the same Starbucks and this guy comes up to me. He's like, Hey man,
I really like your hair. And I was like, God, thanks. And he says, yeah,
I always want a curly hair like that. And I said, Oh yeah. And he said, yeah,
I had long Johnny Depp here. That was like silver and.
And then just walked out. Didn't even get a coffee. It's like,
he came to just look for somebody with cool hair and then walked out,
walked into Starbucks, was homeless. Maybe not.
Maybe people are homeless or maybe they're from Albuquerque. I don't know.
You know? And um,
went to some local restaurants and. And no matter what I do too,
it's like the wrong thing. Like I'll post something. I'll making fun of.
I'm making fun of on my Instagram. And then somebody will write me all, bro.
You're not even going to the right place, man. You make fun of Albuquerque,
but there's a lot of cool places. And then go to another place and then say, Oh,
you got to go to this other place. Then I go to that place. Nah, bro,
you got to go shut the up. I'll just do whatever. You know, it'll be fine.
A place is cool.
It's not cool if you're there for two weeks and you're bored of,
then that's how it is. Hopefully this doesn't make the news. Um,
but it's fine, dude. It's not, it's not, it's not bad. It's not a bad place.
It's actually, the people are really nice. Um, and uh,
you know,
what's really cool about Albuquerque is they don't bother you too much.
Like people aren't in your face like everywhere else. I go, they're more,
they're more like, like, dude, I'm not, I'll tell you what in Albuquerque.
I'm the least famous guy. Nobody, nobody can. I get a picture of so only a very,
very rarely everywhere else I go. Can I get a bit of a bigger picture?
Maybe it's the news thing. Maybe they're tried to boycott me. I don't know.
But um.
Yeah.
I dunno. Albuquerque is a lot of mud huts and it's weird.
It's got this whole like new Mexico's got like it it's so weird how it goes
over. Like from the, from the West coast, California,
the style of California is just kinda whatever.
It just doesn't really have crazy style.
Then you get over to like Arizona and it's got this obvious kind of like sort of
like, I guess like, uh,
like I don't even know how to describe it like this as techie and Indian type
style. And then you get over to New Mexico and it's like,
you're just there pretty much.
It's like got this like Mexican sort of like really like there's no
mistaking this artwork and now it's pretty,
it's always just like tan and Brown and.
And that you see that sun with the, with the, like the thing on the lightweight,
that is everywhere. Like the Albuquerque symbol.
I've never seen a symbol more in a place than Albuquerque.
People have it on the back of their neck.
They get a tattooed due to Albuquerque. Here's the other thing too. And I'm,
and I'm not even knocking it, but you guys, Oh my, my buddy on the, on the,
on the show that we're doing Omari Hardwick, he's on power. He's on this movie.
He got a dope tattoo. I might go to the tattoo place.
But most of the tattoos in the Albuquerque you look like you were just bored and
went to go get the tattoo. And we're like, yeah. Okay. I guess.
And so many's Albuquerque sons with the, um, what do you call it on the, uh,
on Lego it's same thing on the license plate, but anyway, um, and then after,
uh, Santa Santa Fe, after New Mexico, what's after New Mexico,
Texas what's to the East, that's it.
And then it's like kind of gone. It's sort of gone. I mean,
Texas is kind of more cowboy. And then it's gone after Texas is just like,
there's no, like, I, I guess it's influenced from Mexico, I guess.
I don't know I could Google it, but I'm not going to, you know,
so just that's how it is. We learned, so yeah,
I went to the Starbucks. I don't know,
Starbucks stills tastes like a back of a cow's mouth.
I've had some other cool coffee shops that are cool,
but also they're not that good. People are like, you got to go this one,
I go to that one. It's not that good. Also what's up with like,
if it's not painted Brown,
it's painted white and it's so sunny that I needed to get glasses.
I got these sunglasses from sunglass hut. I drove to the mall to do it.
And I was like, I got it. I give up. I was like, I literally, like I was,
I was like, I give up, dude, I it's too bright.
I got to Albuquerque. I was like, it doesn't really matter.
I don't need to get sunglasses. I can just walk around. My opener,
never has sunglasses. He's always just kind of squint. And I was like,
I could do it, bro is brighter here. Did you know that it's brighter here.
So I had to go to the mall. Okay. By the way I go to this mall,
every other store is a shoe store. Now here's the deal. Every other sources,
stores this shoe store. But also I walk in, as soon as I go, there's a walk in,
there's a kiosk of sunglass hut. So I was like, okay, cool. So I say, Hey man,
do you have any like Ray Ray-Bans those are the kinds of like, I was like,
I'm just going to get it. And he was like, ah, we don't have the kind you want.
He said, I said, Oh,
but aren't there other isn't there like another sunglass hut here in the mall.
And he goes like, this there's four. Hi, Hey,
there's four sunglass huts in the mall in Albuquerque
in the Coronado mall. You don't need for
it. Need a wad,
just take the kiosks and put them all in the one one.
You can seriously do that. Academy of glasses,
Academy of lenses put the sunglasses
in the kiosk. Why am I peaking? I'm peaking.
Oh, I'm picking, put the sunglass. Eh,
yeah. Okay. That's better hot.
I guess it sounds like maybe I'm it's going to be a rough one. Um,
so that's what it is here. You're going here.
You got a good news for me. Why? Oh, okay.
All right. Anyway, uh, I, I, we did, we went to sunglass hut.
I went to sunglass hut by myself and I got the glasses and it's all good.
This is so boring. What am I doing here? I don't, I don't, you know what though?
I just feel like you're, you know,
some podcasts are going to be good and some are going to be boring.
I listened to, I listened to some other, uh, some other podcasts and by the way,
I listened to some other podcasts and they're boring as too,
except for some of them are, really interesting.
This one will never be really interesting.
It'll just be kind of funny sometimes.